stay tuned for sports wrap immediately
following the game on 8 news
now all right and thank you for joining
us for our debut of sports wrap right
here on channel 8 i'm chris matthews and
i'm logan reaver well the las vegas
raiders wrapping up that regular season
opener and uh it was an interesting one
to say the least chris yeah really not
what fans were hoping for there in los
angeles lots of raider fans so many
story lines associated with this season
opener and let's head out to sofie
stadium where the game just wrapped up
ron futrell is live on the field hey ron
hey hey there chris yeah a hot muggy day
here in la for the raiders taking on the
uh chargers and starting their season
and you look at what happened here in
this game raiders lose by five points
24-19 they had opportunities towards the
end in the last couple of minutes to win
this game and pull it out still in spite
of all the mistakes and the errors
derek carr sacked three times in the
first half three interceptions uh
bottom line here this game and chris you
and i talked about it beforehand that
it's gonna have the offensive line is
gonna have to do the job to stop the
chargers defense from getting to their
car and they couldn't do that